One of the most common questions I see in
the comments of these videos is,
“Where do I start my microscopy journey?
What kind of microscope should I get if I'm
just starting out?”
Well, that is the very question we were trying
to answer when we created
the Microcosmos Microscopes.
Developed in partnership with our master of
microscopes, James Weiss, they are a fantastic
entry level microscope and it is available
with either plan achromatic objectives or
regular achromatic objectives over at
microcosmos.store/microscope.
And you might be thinking,
“I don't know what an objective is, and
I sure don't know what a plan objective is
or why you want to upgrade your microscope
with them.”
Well, we have a bunch of information about
that over there as well, and also a bunch
of videos about how to use your microscope
when it arrives.
Also, if you previously purchased a Microcosmos
microscope and would like to upgrade your
objectives, we have a four pack of plan objectives
for sale separately as well as brand new 20x
and 60x plan objectives that can be purchased
individually.
You can get all of that and more at Microcosmos.store.
Our master of microscopes, James, was not
in fact always a master.
Like everyone else, he had to start somewhere,
and that “somewhere” was a microscopy
lab course where he saw a scene similar to
this one.
There were thousands and thousands of teeny
tiny things that he didn’t know well enough
to identify.
And these minuscule unknown creatures were
behaving oddly.
They were gathering together on the slide
so tightly that it looked like they were trapped
by invisible walls.
Any time one of them tried to swim away and
escape those walls, it would quickly reverse
its direction and swim right back, like you're
leaving the house, and then you realize
that it's raining and cold and
immediately turn back inside.
In that comparison, you are making an active
decision to turn back.
But for James, new to the wondrous world of
microbes, it was hard to imagine why the creatures
would act like that.
So he asked his instructor what was going
on, but the teacher just said he was
looking at some bacteria and didn’t elaborate.
As you can imagine, this was not a very helpful
answer.
But it wasn’t completely un-helpful either.
After all, before this,
James had just imagined microbes as amorphous
blobs that sit around and get you sick.
But seeing something like this quickly shatters
that image.
It makes bacteria and the other residents
of the microcosmos seem so much more alive
and aware than you’d expect,
from you know, a blob.
Well that’s because microbes are not just blobs.
They are very well-evolved biological machinery,
the product of eons of evolution that have
exposed their ancestors and them to different
homes and foods and threats.
The machine that James was watching in action
there,  was the flagellum, a long helical filament
that either drives the bacteria towards an
area or tumbles it away based on the chemical
it senses in the environment.
The bacteria does this with proteins on its
surface, which then send a signal through
the cell to control the flagellar motor.
This motor then controls the movement of the
flagella, which controls the movement of the cell.
And as we watch more complex organisms, we
can see a similar behavior, like this Euplotes.
It feels wrong to even compare them to a machine
because they seem so cognizant of everything
around them, even without access to all of
the senses that we have available to us.
But they don't have those senses,
because they don’t need them.
These microbes that we are watching have
the same underlying capacity to assemble behavior
out of proteins and ions and signals that
our bodies do.
In fact, our senses and awareness are built
with those same fundamental pieces, they're just
assembled on different scales of size
and time, and complexity.
So even though the pieces are always same,
the scale of  behavior and decisions
are vast when you consider all
the organisms out there and all the choices
they must be facing every single day.
But we journeyers though the microcosmos are
fortunate that scientists have been very curious
about a few species in particular and the
choices they seem capable of.
One species that has been particularly interesting
to learn from is our favorite trumpet-shaped
protists, the Stentors.
Stentors have a kind of odd problem for the
microcosmos:
they are very big.
So big that they have to contend with non-microcosmos
predators, like fish and worms and insect larvae.
To deal with that challenge, Stentor coeruleus
has an ingenious solution:
if it touches something, it curls up in a
ball.
It’s a great solution.
Lovely.
Even a little bit cute.
If a threat approaches you, curl up into
a ball, and what can it really do to you then?
Except that there’s a problem.
A bunch of them really.
When you’re living in a pond surrounded
by other organisms that aren’t fish, how
do you survive if you’re constantly curling
up into yourself?
Wouldn’t that get tiring?
We can see our stentors here are mostly relaxed,
so how do they do that?
How do they figure out what contact is non-threatening?
They learn through a process called
habituation.
If something touches the Stentor, it will
contract away from the force.
But if that force happens again and again
and again, and especially if the force is
not that strong, the stentor becomes less
and less likely to contract.
And stentors are able to remember this for
several hours.
But as much as scientists have watched Stentors
learn and remember, the mechanism that makes
them capable of this is still mysterious to
us.
Another organism that scientists love to watch
learn is slime mold.
In one set of experiments, scientists watched
slime mold move towards food through different
temperature and humidity conditions.
Once an hour, the scientists would expose
the slime to cold, dry air, during which the
slime mold would slow down.
When they were done with the cold exposure
and returned to moist, warm conditions, the
slime mold would pick its speed back up
The scientists repeated this three times,
and then they left the slime molds alone,
keeping them in the warm temperatures that
the organisms prefer.
But even though the scientists were no longer
switching things back to cold, the slime molds
would, an hour later, slow down again as if
they remembered what had happened and expected
it to get cold.
Some would even do it again two and
even three hours later.
Like Stentors, we don’t know the machines
that make this memory and behavior possible.
But we are of course drawn to that mystery,
like bacteria drawn towards an invisible gradient,
we return again and again to the question
that we have not yet answered.
Can these organisms think and remember?
What does it mean to think at all?
Are these organisms just machines?
And if so, are we just machines? The result
of chemical reactions that we do not control.
Or are we something more?
The answers to that probably can not be found
in the microcosmos alone,
but that is no reason not to look.
Thank you for coming on this journey with us as
we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
And if you are interested in exploring that
world on your own, I will remind you there's
a link in the description to the Microcosmos
Microscope, a microscope we made specifically
for people who are starting off on their journey.
It can be a little bit complicated and intimidating
at first, but that microscope comes along
with a few things to help you on your journey,
including a mount for your phone so you can
video whatever you're seeing, and also a series
of videos that we made to help you get the
best out of your microscope.
The people on the screen right now are our
Patreon patrons.
They're a bunch of people who think that there
should be weird, chill content about microscopic
organisms on YouTube.
Obviously, we agree with them, but we could
not do this on our own.
So we are so grateful to all of the people
who help us out at Pareon.com/JourneytoMicro.
If you'd like to see your name up here, that
is the place to go.
If you want to see more from our master of
microscopes, James Weiss.
You can check out Jam and Germs on Instagram.
And if you want to see more from us, there's
probably a subscribe button somewhere nearby.